so you brought up capitalism earlier and
there are a lot of people who love
capitalism and a lot of people
who really really
don't and
it struck me
recently that the
what's happening with capitalism here is
exactly analogous to the way in which
Super intelligence might wipe us out
so
you know you know I studied economics
for my undergrad Stockholm School of
Economics yay
well no no I tell me someone's very
interested in how how you could use
Market forces to just get stuff done
more efficiently but give the right
incentives to the market so that it
wouldn't do really bad things
so Dylan had Phil Manel who's a a
professor and colleague of mine at MIT
wrote this really interesting paper with
some collaborators recently
where they proved mathematically that if
you just up take one goal that you just
optimize for
on and on and on indefinitely
do you think he's gonna
bring you in the right direction
but basically always happens is in the
beginning it will make things better for
you
but if you keep going at some point
that's going to start making things
worse for you again and then gradually
it's going to make it really really
terrible so just as a simple
the way I think of the proof is
like suppose you want to go from here
back to Austin for example and you're
like okay yeah let's just let's go south
but you put in exactly the right sort of
the right direction just optimize that
South as possible you get closer and
closer to Austin
but uh there's always some little error
So you you're not going exactly towards
Austin but you get pretty close but
eventually you start going away again
and eventually you're going to be
leaving the solar system yeah and they
they proved it's a beautiful
mathematical proof this happens
generally
and this is very important for AI
because for even though Stuart Russell
has
written a book and given a lot of talks
on why it's a bad idea to have ai to
blindly optimize something that's what
pretty much all our systems do yeah we
have something called the loss function
that we're just minimizing or reward
function we just minimize maximizing
stuff
and um
capitalism is exactly like that too we
want we wanted to get stuff done more
efficiently the people wanted so
we introduce the free market
things got done much more efficiently
than they did in
say communism right and it got better
but then it just kept optimizing it and
kept optimizing and you got every bigger
companies and every more efficient
information processing and now also very
much powered by I.T
and uh eventually a lot of people are
beginning to feel weight we're kind of
optimizing a bit too much like why did
we just chop down half the rainforest
you know and why why did suddenly these
Regulators get
captured by lobbyists and so on it's
just the same optimization that's been
running for too long
if you have an AI that actually has
power over the world and you just give
it one goal and just like keep
optimizing that most likely everybody's
gonna be like Yay this is great in the
beginning things are getting better
but um it's almost impossible to give it
exactly the right direction to optimize
in and then
eventually all hey Breaks Loose right
Nick Bostrom and others are given the
example to sound quite silly like what
if you just want to like
tell it
cure cancer or something and that's all
you tell it maybe it's going to decide
the
take over entire continents just so we
can get more super computer facilities
in there and
figure out how to cure cancer backwards
and then you're like wait that's not
what I wanted right and
um
the the the issue with capitalism and
the issue with runaway I have kind of
merged now because the malloc I talked
about
is exactly the capitalist molloch that
we have built an economy that has
optimizing for only one thing
profit
right and that worked great back when
things were very inefficient and then
now it's getting done better and it
worked great as long as the companies
were small enough that they couldn't
capture the regulators
but
that's not true anymore but they keep
optimizing
and now
they realize that that they can these
companies can make even more profit by
building ever more powerful AI even if
it's Reckless
but optimize more and more and more and
more and more
so this is molok again showing up and I
just want to anyone here who has any
concerns about about uh late stage
capitalism having gone a little too far
you should worry about
super intelligence because it's the same
villain in both cases it's more like and
optimizing one objective function
aggressively blindly is going to take us
there yeah we have this pause from time
to time and look into our hearts and ask
why are we doing this is this uh am I
still going towards Austin or have I
gone too far you know maybe we should
change direction
and that is the idea behind the halt for
six months what six months it seems like
a very short period just can we just
linger and explore different ideas here
because this feels like a really
important moment in human history where
pausing would actually have a
significant positive effect
we said six months because we figured
the number one pushback we're gonna get
in the west was like but China
and
everybody knows there's no way that
China is going to catch up with the West
on this in six months so it's that
argument goes off the table and you can
forget about geopolitical competition
and just focus on
the real issue that's why we put this
that's really interesting but you've
already made the case that uh even for
China if you actually want to take on
that argument China too would not be
bothered by a longer halt because they
don't want to lose control even more
than the West doesn't
that's what I think that's a really
interesting argument like I have to
actually really think about that which
the the kind of thing people assume is
if you develop an AGI
that open AI if they're the ones that do
it for example they're going to win but
you're saying no they're everybody loses
yeah it's gonna get better and better
and better and then Kaboom we all lose
that's what's gonna happen